[Music]
on this friday night
hospitals at a breaking point it is the
most busy we've ever been
the perilous mission to move fragile
patients to other facilities
rising cases rising travel restrictions
what needs to happen to relax rules this
summer
plus the new group of canadians now
eligible for the astrazeneca shot
as canada reports a new blood clot case
and recycled rocket
the space and sustainability mission
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight
robin gill good evening and thank you
for joining us
ontario's health care system is being
crushed under the weight of an
unrelenting third wave hospitals and
icus have reached a breaking point
there are more than 2 200 people in
hospital
including 818 in intensive care that's a
new record in ontario
and it's pushing stretched resources to
the brink out of sheer desperation
critically ill patients in covet hot
spots are now being transferred
to make room for more it is the most
severe phase of the pandemic yet
and the pressure is mounting in our top
story tonight jeff semple gives us a
rare look
at how the province is managing critical
care and the tough choices that lie
ahead
multiple times a day staff at this
toronto hospital
now perform a delicate dance this woman
in her early 60s tested positive for
covid19 a few days ago
struggling to breathe she had to be
intubated this ventilator
a breathing machine is keeping her alive
but now she has to move
our icu now is currently completely full
the hospital's intensive care unit home
to the sickest patients
is overwhelmed they've even built
makeshift icu
additions with extra beds in other areas
of the hospital
but they simply don't have enough staff
there's a profound shortage of icu
nurses
so they worked the phones calling other
hospitals in the region
and they found one in the small
community of aurelia
about a 90 minutes drive north which has
agreed to accept the patient
the challenge is getting her there
orange is an ontario non-profit that
provides air ambulance rescue and
medical transportation services
they've been shuttling patients to
hospitals for more than 40 years
but they've never experienced anything
like the past couple of weeks
there's nothing we can compare it to it
is the most busy we've ever been more
than 1200 covid19 patients have been
transferred so far this year
nearly half of those coming in just the
month of april
they rely on a small fleet of ambulances
a dozen helicopters
and they've just borrowed some buses
equipped to carry two covid19 patients
at a time they have portable machines
and they have portable
monitors so everything is is
miniaturized to be able to do that this
bus is transporting a couple of covid
patients from the toronto area to
another hospital
three hours away in kingston so right
now a lot of this accelerated transfers
has been to try to get as many
people out of the gta as possible to
fill up places like kingston
and those outside but as a result
kingston is now filling up and moving
some of its patients to ottawa while
others head to different
smaller communities across the province
is there an element of risk in moving
some of these patients there's always
risk
even just going from here in the
hospital if you were to go from one
floor to the next floor but so far
no covid patients have died in transit
hospital staff say they only move those
who are in stable condition
they no longer require the family's
consent
and that's the hard part unfortunately
we're in a system where we often have no
choice because otherwise we would not be
able to support
everybody jeff semple global news
toronto
the situation in alberta is growing more
serious by the day
almost 1700 new cases were reported
today
more contagious variants are driving the
rapid spread and doctors are warning
albertans could be in for a crisis
similar to hard hit ontario but as
heather york's west reports
jason kennedy's government still has no
plans to toughen up restrictions
for those born between 1967 and 1981
this week brought new hope after
becoming eligible for the astrid zenica
vaccine
gen xers flooded social media with
selfies
adding in a healthy dose of nostalgia
too i'm
pro vaccine selfie it's a way that we
can normalize
uh vaccination for for people who might
be a little bit hesitant who might be a
little bit
a little bit concerned but beyond the
immunization rollout alberta's covet
situation
is bleak daily infection numbers have
now climbed to highs not seen since the
peak of alberta's second wave
leaving doctors to brace for the weeks
ahead i have friends that are working in
ontario
general internists colleagues in the
intensive care units or sending out
distress signals
that's going to happen here we're
looking at where those those cases are
and where the spread is happening
alberta's health minister blames the
province's current spike on gatherings
over the easter weekend
but the government is still hoping
restrictions announced two weeks ago
will be enough to turn things around
this week because of a modernist
shipment delay
a mobile vaccine clinic planned for
workers at the high river cargill meat
packing plant
the place where more than 900 workers
fell ill last year
had to be postponed highlighting that
beyond the sea of vaccine selfies
many essential workers are still
vulnerable every one of us that have had
to palliate a family member
on a facetime zoom
i mean that leaves cars like
i don't know how to tell people
that other people matter that's gonna
happen
a nightmare already playing out in one
part of canada
appears primed and ready to start
playing out here as well
heather urex west global news calgary
there is some promising news about
canada's trajectory
new federal modeling shows stricter
public health measures have helped slow
the surge
for the first time in many weeks the
national rt value has dipped below one
that number tells us how many people a
single infected person gives the virus
to
if it stays consistently below one the
spread of the disease is slowing
now that more people are getting
vaccinated canada's top doctor says
it may be safe to lift restrictions this
summer
these models give us hope illustrating
that there is a
safe way to lift most restrictive public
health measures
by this summer if enough people get
vaccinated
the key point there is that enough
people must be vaccinated
as of today 27.5 percent of the
population has received at least one
dose
only 2.6 percent has been fully
vaccinated with both doses
something that could help speed up
vaccinations the national advisory
council on immunization is now
recommending astrazeneca be offered to
canadians
30 and up tonight abigail beeman reports
on where canada's rollout needs to be
for restrictions to ease and why
combating vaccine hesitancy
will be crucial are you
i am very excited justin trudeau's first
shot
his wife sophie got hers too she didn't
need her hand held
getting the astrazeneca vaccine is a
shot in the arm for the government's
tagline that the best vaccine is the one
you can get
undermined an hour later by the
country's national advisory committee on
immunization
nancy recommends that the astro seneca
kova 19 vaccine
may be offered to individuals 30 years
of age and older
without contra indications if the
individual does not wish to wait for an
mrna vaccine and the benefits
outweigh the risk yet again changing
advice from nasty
acknowledging some people want to wait
and they seem to suggest
with good reason nasty continues to
preferentially recommend
authorized mrna cova 19 vaccines i don't
think we should be vaccine shopping
at all if we're going to get the vaccine
especially if we have an underlying
medical condition
dr neil rao says the perception
astrazeneca is an economy class vaccine
compared to first class mrna
is unfortunate having too much
information sometimes can be very
challenging for people to understand
and it could lead to vaccine hesitancy
that's a speed bump on the road to
normalcy
we just don't know exactly how big it is
that
large part of the population that may be
sitting on the fence or maybe is a bit
hesitant you know
you can see what the difference is the
country's top doctors presented a new
type of slide friday for the first time
showing the conditions
under which restrictions could be lifted
this summer without overwhelming
hospitals
20 percent of canadians would need their
second shot
and 75 percent their first at this
point restrictive measures could be
gradually eased
as long as adequate tests trace isolate
capacity
and individual precautions are
maintained but the modeling shows
hospitals
will be overwhelmed even if that first
dose coverage
drops to 55 percent of canadians and of
course the other piece of the puzzle is
supply ontario and alberta have already
said they won't give astrazeneca to
people in their 30s
simply because they don't have enough
abigail beeman global news
ottawa ontario has reported its first
case of extremely rare blood clots
linked to the astrazeneca
kova shield vaccine the province says
the case involves a man in his 60s he is
now recovering at home
this is the fourth case of a blood clot
in canada out of more than 1.1 million
covashill doses administered health
canada insists the benefits
outweigh the risks pregnant women are
now eligible for coven 19 vaccines in
ontario
the province moved the group up the
priority list after seeing growing
evidence that pregnant women are at
increased risk of severe illness the
society of obstetricians and
gynecologists of canada
has called on all provinces to
prioritize pregnant women
new brunswick made the move earlier this
week
new brunswick is now imposing tougher
measures after detecting
multiple cases related to travel
starting tomorrow
non-essential travelers some business
travelers and people moving to new
brunswick must isolate for at least
seven
days at a designated hotel at their own
expense
people who don't need to enter the
province are being told to stay away
right now if you don't need to come to
new brunswick
don't come here we want you just not
right now
next door in nova scotia a near total
lockdown is now in effect in the halifax
region
for days cases have been rising today
the province reported
44 new infections that's the biggest
daily jump
in a year the bc government has revealed
details of its clampdown on
non-essential travel
effective immediately the order
restricts movement for recreational
purposes across
three regional zones it's still okay to
travel for things like school work and
health care
periodic road checks will be in place at
key corridors
to discourage non-essential travel those
who break the rules could face a 575
dollar fine
the changes are in effect until may 25th
there are stunning developments in our
ongoing coverage of sexual misconduct
allegations in the military
at a parliamentary committee looking
into the accusations major kelly brennan
delivered
bombshell testimony against former chief
of the defense staff
general jonathan vance now a former key
aide to the prime minister
is shedding light on what justin
trudeau's office knew
about the allegations david aiken
reports
30-year army veteran major kelly brennan
spent two full days being interrogated
by
military investigators and she told mps
thursday
that general jonathan vance told her
what to tell them
definitely he gave me very many
consequences if i was not
following his orders she said there were
no threats of bodily harm
but she also testified that vance who
had just retired as chief of the defense
staff or
cds was not worried about the
consequences of his actions
the cds told me he was untouchable
nor was vance worried about his civilian
bosses
like the defense minister harjit sagin
general vance always told me that
he always had them under control brennan
also told the committee that
vance fathered two children with her
global news spoke with vance in february
and at that time he denied all
allegations of sexual misconduct and
he also denied having fathered children
with brennan
the military investigation into vance's
alleged misconduct continues
meanwhile the political fallout
escalated elder marquez
a former top political aide in the prime
minister's office
testified friday that back in 2018
trudeau's chief of staff
katie telford knew about an allegation
of potential misconduct by vance
and that marquez kept her informed of
developments the important
sensitive and unusual nature of this
matter was immediately obvious to me
even in the absence of any details
regarding the allegation
it is the first time anyone has
confirmed that telford
trudeau's closest highest-ranking and
longest-serving political advisor
was in the loop and yet neither trudeau
nor sagin
acted on the allegations instead they
extended
vance's tenure as canada's top general
and gave him a raise
telford in a statement friday repeated
what sajin and trudeau have said all
along
that the appropriate steps were taken at
the time but that improvements to the
system
are in the works there are of course uh
lots
of things we need to add to and create
better processes for
but that is something we continue to
work on david aiken global news
ottawa it's the vessel that vanished in
deep waters coming up why search crews
only have a few hours left
to find those on board
and lift off speed
space and sustainability are connecting
on the final frontier
spacex and nasa successfully launched
four astronauts into orbit
early this morning using a recycled
falcon 9 rocket
and a reused dragon capsule crew 2
will arrive at the international space
station on saturday and will spend the
next six months at the lab
before heading back to earth inside the
same spacecraft
that got them there time is running out
to find a missing indonesian submarine
which disappeared off the coast of bali
on wednesday
the sub now has less than a day's supply
of oxygen for the 53 people on board
and there are fears the vessel may have
sunk so deep that it won't be able to
handle the pressure
indonesia's navy believes an electrical
failure caused the sub to lose control
during a training exercise still ahead
those blue skies over alberta
are producing a green boom
alberta is set to lead the country in
the growth of wind and solar resources
according to canada's energy regulator
and as far nasa reports
displaced workers in the oil and gas
sector are counting on the green side
of the energy sector like many albertans
drew mayor's career has been shaped in
the boom and bust
of oil and gas but in the bust of 2015
he took a chance and then i decided it
was time for a change
an electrician by trade he turned his
skills to a new form of energy
solar it's just such a underutilized
resource that
you know shines especially in alberta
mayor charted a new course started his
own company it was slow at first but now
i'm swamped business is booming
his team is paneling roof after roof
with no bust in sight
across oil country a construction boom
with new projects of staggering scale
propelled by sunny market conditions
we're the sunshine state of the north
green gate power is developing this
immense project
that will power more than a hundred
thousand homes and employ
500 in its construction we have a lot of
skilled labor
here in alberta i believe a lot of those
skills are easily transferable to
renewable energy projects the boom is
due in part to the sliding dominance
of fossil fuels especially the drive to
phase out coal
canada's energy regulator forecasts the
province's wind power capacity will
double by 2023
and solar will soar many times higher
it is a really remarkable thing how
quickly costs have fallen for wind
and solar over the last number of years
about seven years ago in my previous
service here on the montana first nation
and mask watches
under the leadership of chief leonard
standing on the road
drew mayer now oversees the largest
solar farm on indigenous land in canada
we can do it because it's coming into
play and
just the right timing perfect timing the
farm just went online
last october and when that thing got
activated it cut our power in half
so we knew that we were onto something
it's a shining source of pride here
where wealth was once grounded in oil
until the wells went dry since then
montana has made the shift
one by one key buildings were arrayed
with solar of their own
and all feeding the grid through
montana's own renewable energy company
and for young people here a future in a
resource
that will never run out oh it's made a
big difference
in our attitude of our nation members
that they're really
looking at it as an opportunity for
careers
for mayor montana is an inspiration
wherever there's
wind and sun it just goes to show that
even though montana is a small nation
with the right people in place and the
right desire you can accomplish these
these types of projects fara nasser
global news toronto
with the third wave comes a career
crisis up next
why some healthcare workers are ready to
quit
for more than a year health care workers
have endured long
stressful shifts to care for patients
suffering with coven 19.
they're exhausted burnt out and in some
cases struggling with post-traumatic
stress
now this third and most threatening wave
is upon them
as christa hassi explains many are
rethinking their careers
and making a difficult choice so just
finishing up shift today on the covid
unit
we're starting to see our
hospitalizations climb steadily
dr nisha bakshi is the internal medicine
lead at the royal alexandra hospital in
edmonton
she's also in charge of the hospital's
covet response
dr bakshi says these days it's been hard
to fill shifts on the kovit ward
everybody's tired of it it's exhausting
to work on the covet unit
it's a grim reality as canada fights the
third wave of the pandemic
icu beds are full patients are younger
and sicker
and it's taking a toll on health care
workers dr bakshi actually holds the
record for the most days spent on the
coveted ward at her hospital
but she says it's come at a cost in
january she was diagnosed with
post-traumatic stress disorder
or ptsd i noticed that i was having
difficulty sleeping i was having a lot
of nightmares
i was reliving and replaying
conversations i had with families
she got help and now hopes others in the
medical field will do the same
none of what we went through was normal
we all showed up and did our jobs
but we're not okay and it's okay to say
that
close to 70 percent of all health care
workers reported worsening mental health
during the pandemic
according to statistics canada
psychologist melanie jones provides
counseling for healthcare workers
she says a lot of her clients are
exhausted and burnt out
people are looking at this and saying i
have nothing else to give
just as hospitals race to increase their
capacity some in the health care field
are walking away from the profession
they love
or are considering it you could create
the 5 000 physical beds
but if we don't have the right skilled
staff we will quickly get overwhelmed
how worried are you about hospitals
capacity to treat people during the
third wave
and into the future acutely right now
i'm very worried so i think you're we're
going to have a
a challenge with people with just enough
people to to run the show
christa hessie global news toronto
for more on the wave of covet fatigue
hitting canadian healthcare you can
watch the new reality with donna friesen
tomorrow night at 7
right here on global so many health care
workers are going above and beyond right
now including nurse amy lin
in ottawa
[Music]
she was just transferred to a struggling
icu and brought along her guitar to race
spirits
so we leave you tonight with more of her
serenade to patience
thank you for watching and i hope to see
you back here tomorrow good
not
night
you are not alone